[Music]
hey there guys thanks for tuning in in
this video I'm gonna train you how to
run faster like Sonic the Hedgehog
[Music]
so if you want to run faster and I'm
presuming you do as you're watching this
video then there are two areas that you
can focus on one is the biomechanics
that's the technique of your running you
know the way you're hitting the floor
with your feet one after the other and
moving your arms these are the basics of
running and the other part is the
muscular force that you're able to exert
on the ground so running is very much to
do with the amount of force you can
exert on the floor in the short amount
of time that your feet are touching it
because obviously they need to then
launch off again very quickly so
starting with the biomechanics so what's
the best way to run in order to increase
your speed and are you currently running
in the best way possible
one thing I've often wondered is why in
animes and also Sonic the Hedgehog
people tend to run with their arms
behind their back like that I mean it
looks sort of cool until you try it
yourself and then it really doesn't look
cool makes you look like a bit of a knob
it looks cool but one thing I can tell
you is the reason that they do that is
not because it's at all based on reality
there is no advantage to running with
your arms behind your back there's some
theory that ninjas would have done it so
they were ready to grab a sword or that
maybe they're running so fast it's
blowing their arms behind them and they
can't bring them forwards but then that
makes them sound quite weak being a mind
how powerful the legs will be are at the
end of the day there's no advantage to
keeping your arms behind you in fact
swinging your arms is one of the most
effective ways to increase your speed
and if you want to get an immediate
speed boost then my recommendation is
just be a bit more mindful of the way
you're moving your arms as you run
really pump them don't swing up too high
keep your arms hands open so that there
are aerodynamic but really feel the
power as you swing your arms back and
forth and that will drive you forwards
much faster the other thing you need to
do in order to run faster is get gravity
on your side and that means that
basically you need to essentially be
falling forwards as you're running so
that's the part that the anime's and
slightly Hedgehog depictions have
correct because they're always leaning
very far forwards and that is the
correct way to run and this is
relatively new information for a long
time people used to run striking the
ground with the heels first leaning back
slightly as they did and this is partly
a result of
where we wear shoes with large padded
heels and so it's more comfortable to
strike with our heels but this is
actually incorrect because when you do
that your center of gravity is behind
your legs so means you can't use your
feet and your knees as they're actually
designed to use actually your your foot
and your knee and your ankle are all
supposed to compress directly underneath
your body almost like a spring and if
you look at it cheetah or a leopard
you'll see they have these actually
weird feet where their toes like that
and then the upper portion that the back
portion of their feet stick up like so
and this allows the foot to become an
additional hinge in that spring giving
you even more power and the human foot
can do the same thing but not if you're
reaching your heel forwards so earlier I
recorded some footage to demonstrate say
hello Adam from the purse there are two
techniques called Qi running and pose
running both of these teach people to
lean more forwards and to essentially
tip forward until they're going to fall
and then put their leg out in front of
them to stop themselves from doing that
so they can keep on plowing forwards and
if you do this then you're not only
running faster because you've got
gravity pulling you forwards but also
because your feet they're acting more
like a hinge and your center of gravity
is directly above your knees this is
also reduced your likelihood of damaging
your knees your footwear is also
obviously really important not only
because certain shoes have got springy
materials in the soles and things but
also because of the amount of soul that
they have in general and the connection
this gives you to the floor so you can
have structured shoes which are more
supportive and tend to have bigger heel
to toe drops or you can have minimalist
shoes and minimalist shoes are
essentially the minimal amount of
material between your foot and the
ground and that allows your foot to bend
the way it's supposed to
by that remember and also means you can
actually use your feet muscles slightly
as you stride encourages you to strike
with a mid or forefoot strike so that
you're hitting the ground with the ball
of your foot as you're leaning forwards
or with the middle of your foot as
you're leaning forwards rather than
reaching forwards as we discussed with
your heel so if you want to immediately
fix your technique slightly look for a
slightly more minimalist shoe and that
should improve your ability to naturally
run slightly more leaning forwards
there's two other tricks we can use to
quickly fix our biomechanics
one is to increase the height of our
center of gravity cuz studies show that
actually the higher your center of
gravity the faster you can run because
you've got more gravity on your side as
you fall forwards someone very tall with
heavy shoulders is able to lean forwards
and gravity pulls them in the correct
direction they put their feet out just
in front of them and they run faster as
a result so that it's not just the extra
leg length that makes you faster when
you're taller it's also that heightens
center of gravity your center of gravity
by the way is normally just below your
navel so how can you increase your
center of gravity well this is just a
theory probably won't work but I'm
thinking beefed up your shoulders
heavier shoulders higher center of
gravity leaning forwards as you run
probably not going to notice a huge
difference there but something
interesting and there's another reason
not to wear overly heavy Footwear the
other way we can fix our biomechanics
immediately and this is quite cool is
with something called over speed
training and I love the name over speed
training so what are you doing today oh
nothing just over speed training there
over speed training basically means that
you're running faster than you normally
could and you do this by running down a
hill by having someone tow you in a car
and you've got like something attached
to your waist or even on a treadmill
turning up the speed to a very high
setting or they need to be careful with
that because treadmills actually do
affect your biomechanics and they impact
on the amount of muscle you need to use
because the floor is moving underneath
you but anyways the idea behind over
speed training whichever method you use
is that you're running faster than you
normally can and as you're teaching your
body the way it needs to move to go at
that speed so you're creating movement
patterns for your nervous system it's a
very cool idea I'm not sure if it
definitely works but it's certainly a
cool thing to try assuming you don't
mind falling over and being dragged
behind a car it is a little bit
dangerous and I can't be held
responsible if that happens to you I've
never tried it running down hills though
that's a fairly normal thing to do and
probably safe enough so now that we've
talked about the biomechanics the next
thing we need to think about is how
we're going to generate that amount of
power and one way to do this is quite
simply with weight training weight
training will allow you to increase the
fast twitch muscle fibers in the legs
and also in the shoulders so I talked
about the importance of swinging your
shoulders as you run them that focusing
on that can give
instant speed boost so why not also give
them extra strength by training them in
the gym one move I particularly like for
doing this is called a dumbbell run as I
got them from Sylvester Stallone's book
sly moves you actually holds dumbbells
in your hands and you move one forwards
in a kind of hammer curl and the other
one you do a tricep extension and at the
same time you're driving it upwards
thereby training the anterior deltoids
so I'll build you up bigger shoulders
and you'll because also can train them
in all the other normal ways that you
train your shoulders and that'll help me
generate more power in your upper body
for running obviously more important is
the power that we're generating in the
lower body and that means you want to
train our posterior chain you can do
that obviously with running and if you
sprint and of course that will train the
fast twitch muscle fibers the basics of
training I've said this before a said
specific adaptation to impose demands
that basically means that your body
adapts to get good or whatever you make
it do a lot so if you want to be able to
splinter sprint a lot an explosive
jumping also will train those fast
twitch muscle fibers in the posterior
chain another exercise that's supposed
to be very good for this is kettlebell
swings and of course you've got your
squats in your deadlifts all of that
will give you more explosive power you
can exert on the ground of course just
sprinting isn't the most exciting way to
get better at sprinting though so if you
want to increase the challenge one thing
we can do is to add more resistance and
one Kawai I found to think that is to
attach a parachute to my back the
parachute I bought is actually not the
most effective it doesn't offer that
much resistance but it certainly looks
cool in a video either that or it looks
really weird and I think people are
staring at me when I was filming this
there are other more normal ways to add
resistance so running up a hill we had
running down a hill now we've got
running up a hill running on sand of
course or even running through shallow
water which will also force you to
develop more strength and then when you
go and sprint without that added
resistance you you'll be like lightning
like greased lightning I don't know why
I'm quoting Greece in this video that's
weird there are also a ton of cool
exercises and drills specifically for
training the muscles that you use in
sprinting one is marching aids one is
high knees we just literally beat
getting them as high as you can and that
is perfect for generating that force in
the short map timing if we touch the
ground you can push things along there
plenty of exercises like that and if you
type speed drills into Google or YouTube
then you'll find a whole plethora of
them coming up one cool exercise I came
across as something called ass kicked so
you're basically standing on one leg and
then you jump in the air and kick your
own butt with the leg that you just
jumped off that's an exercise that will
kick your ass and the idea of course is
that you're exerting as much power and
force on the ground as possible once
again in order to push yourself off when
you do come to running your calves also
play a big role in running of course and
another cool exercise I found to Train
neighs is calf jumps so here you're
jumping off the floor without bending
your knees or any other part of your leg
literally just using your toes to exert
enough force to propel yourself into the
air looks ridiculous but it's quite a
cool workout for your calves and a
unique case of a bodyweight workout for
your calves and if you're going to be
using more minimalist shoes then you can
also increase your speed by
strengthening the muscles in your feet
because your feet actually have a lot of
muscles in them and they can be used to
push off the ground as well in fact your
toes can even somewhat grip the ground
if you have a thin enough sole and the
best way to train your feet unless you
are going to get into Tomioka togher
which I have not looked into myself is
to try running barefoot on sand in which
case the muscles in your feet will be
working a lot harder and as you
understand you're not very like to
injure yourself you can also try those
minimalist gloves shoes like the Vibram
FiveFingers but you need to be very
careful when doing that because you've
been running in regular shoes probably
your whole life and you're not used to
running completely barefoot yet if you
run too fast or too hard right at the
start then you can risk injury and I
actually hurt my knee that way it took a
couple of years to get better stretching
might also be able to help you run
faster by actually loosening up the
antagonistic muscles so if you're
running you use your calves in order to
push off the ground but meanwhile your
tibialis anterior which is the muscle on
the front of the shin the one that
causes pain when you get shin splints
that actually pulls your foot in the
other direction and actually offers a
little bit resistance when you're
running so if you stretch that muscle
then you can actually make it looser
thereby enabling yourself to exert more
force
your calves as you push yourself off the
key though is not to train the tibialis
anterior before you run as actually some
studies suggest that stretching before
you run can actually slow you down and
increase your chance of injury by
reducing your control over those muscles
so what you need to do instead is just
stretch the rest of the time not during
your running but just after your running
or in your workouts when you're not
actually on the track and this will then
make those muscles offer less resistance
when you do come to running again and if
you subscribe to the notions of muscle
control as outlined by max ik then
theoretically you could gain conscious
control over the tibialis anterior and
relax it with your own mind as you exert
more force with the calf but that's top
level stuff and I don't think we're
going to really get into that now of
course you then also have the amount of
energy that you have for running and you
need to think about things like your vo2
Max and your circulation to make sure
that you can keep up that top speed for
as long as possible but that's something
that we're going to talk about in a
future video because it's beyond the
scope of this one so everything you've
found some slightly different ideas
there to what's in a lot of the other
videos I'm running faster some things
like stretching your calf muscles and
things like using over speed trading
maybe you haven't heard of before but
the most practical things are just used
that running where you're leaning more
forwards try out more minimalist shoes
and power through with your shoulders
you can do that and train your legs at
the same time then you should be able to
see a decent increase in speed so thanks
for watching guys hope you found that
interesting and useful something a bit
different and yeah let me know if you
have any other ideas that I missed on
how to run faster or if you have any
questions for me and I'll be happy to
answer them in the comments below stay
tuned for more videos coming soon
obviously christmas is coming up so
there might be a short break but I'll
try and get something out pronto when I
get back I'm gonna be doing some
workouts still got that video I'm Bruce
Lee's philosophy on the way and I'm also
going to be doing a video on
transcranial direct current stimulation
various other interesting things so if
that sounds good then please stay tuned
to subscribe maybe like this video maybe
share it because that'll help me an
awful lot and Merry Christmas and I hope
you have an awesome new year and I will
see you soon bye for now
you